in Chesapeake Virginia we're learning
more now about the six people who police
say were shot to death by a manager at a
Walmart Supercenter now one of the
victims according to his family had said
the gunman used to give him a hard time
the oldest person who died was 70 the
youngest just 16 as Jeffrey gays reports
their loved ones cannot believe this
happened
this man you can't even describe it's
pain that is all too familiar for
families left grieving from America's
latest mass shooting this Chesapeake
Virginia Walmart is where the tragedy is
still fresh Sonya is the aunt of Tanika
Johnson how do you know you go out to go
to work
and you not coming home 22 year old
Johnson was one of the six Walmart
employees killed Tuesday night in
addition to 70 year old Randy Blevins 43
year old Lorenzo gamble 38 year old
Brian Pendleton 52 year old Kelly Pyle
and a 16 year old who is still not been
identified there was a person down
that's still down police say the first
shots were fired in the break room
around 10 p.m and it started
slaughtering everybody investigators say
the shooter was 31 year old Andre Bing
who worked as a night team manager and
been employed by the retailer since he
was a teenager and it is by the grace of
God that a bullet missed me the shooter
was armed with a handgun and additional
rounds of ammunition injuring at least
six others before turning the gun on
himself I literally watched bodies drop
this latest mass shooting as the state
is still grappling with the murders of
three football players at the University
of Virginia
allegedly shot by a former teammate just
10 days earlier Governor Glenn young can
acknowledged the concern over the
back-to-back mass killings in the
Commonwealth there will be time for us
to react
but today and in the next few days is a
time to support those that need us most
for CBS mornings Jeff begays in
Chesapeake Virginia